le télétravail augmente la vulnérabilité
des travailleurs sur les fameuses trois
dimensions qui sont présentés comme des
dimensions libératrice quand on propose
plus d'indépendance et qu'on dit voilà
les travailleurs vont retrouver la
maîtrise de leur temps pour pouvoir
organiser leur temps qu'est ce qu'on
constate finalement dans l'expérience
c'est que cette maîtrise elle consiste à
un allongement du temps de travail on
travaille très tôt le matin au travail
jusqu'à très tard le soir
parfois on est tellement pris par son
télétravail qu'on en oublie de faire une
pause déjeuner j'ai lu des articles qui
racontait que une personne qui
télétravaillent à la maison garder son
pc sur ses genoux pour aller aux
toilettes enfin voilà des histoires
comme ça on a tous vécu ça on l'a tous
observés autour de nous on voit bien
qu'on a cette extension du temps de
travail sur la question de l'agilité on
nous présente le télétravail comme le
moyen de mieux articuler vie privée et
vie personnelle
piper pardon vie privée et vie
professionnelle mieux articuler
peut-être en effet on peut garder ses
enfants on en a fait l'expérience ça
aussi peut-être les amener à l'école etc
mais ce que l'on constate aussi c'est
qu'il y ait en fait une dilution entre
le temps privé et le temps professionnel
une dilution entre la notion de loisir
et la notion de travail qui va pour moi
dans le sens d'une prise de position de
plus en plus larges du travail dans nos
vies en ouvrant le domicile au travail
on lui ouvre l'intégralité de nos vies
et enfin dernièrement sur la question de
la performance là aussi le télétravail
est présenté comme le moyen d'augmenter
la performance puisque on ne serait plus
dérangés par qui que ce soit pendant son
travail on peut bien se concentrer très
bien je pose une question qu'est ce
qu'un travail qui n'est pas dérangé que
vaut un travail qui n'a pas donné lieu à
une contestation à une discussion à des
échanges peut être à l'arrivée d'une
idée imprévus qui viendrait d'un
collègue
et n'est ce pas finalement une sorte de
taschereau nisation accéléré d'ailleurs
il ya un article qui est paru
aujourd'hui dans les echos qui parlait
de neo taylorisation du travail
en télétravail c'est à dire qu'on est
finalement canton télétravail et bien on
répète sans cesse les mêmes tâches
puisqu'on est seul avec soi même donc on
tourne en boucle et je n'y vois pas un
progrès
[Musique]